>> Laura: IT'S TIME FOR OUR
"SEEN AND UNSEEN" SEGMENT WILL
RE-EXPOSE THE BIG CULTURAL
STORIES OF THE DAY.
WELL, NEW CASE OF CELEBRITY
INJUSTICE.
LATE-NIGHT HOSTS IN HOLLYWOOD
ARE MELTING DOWN OVER THE
MUELLER NEWS AND WHY IS THE POPE
WITHHOLDING HIS RING FROM THE
FAITHFUL?
JOINING US WITH ALL THE DETAILS,
RAYMOND ARROYO, FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR, "NEW YORK TIMES"
BEST-SELLING AUTHOR OF THE
BRAND-NEW BOOK "WORLD WHILE HER,
THE AMULET OF POWER."
THE LEFT LOSING THEIR MINDS OVER
THE REPORTING OF THE MALL
REPORT.
>> LATE-NIGHT LAND IS REALLY
IMPLODING AND IT'S NOT A PRETTY
SCENE.
THERE IS A GREAT SADNESS AND
LATE-NIGHT.
HERE IS TREVOR NOAH.
>> LITTLE DISAPPOINTED.
IT'S LIKE COMING DOWN THE STAIRS
ON CHRISTMAS MORNING.
YOU WERE HOPING FOR A BRAND-NEW
BMX BUT INSTEAD YOU FIND SANTA'S
DEAD BODY.
WE HAVE FOOTAGE FROM WHEN HE
FOUND OUT THAT MUELLER HAD LET
HIM OFF THE HOOK.
>> WHEN IT COMES TO DONALD J.
TRUMP'S COLLISION WITH RUSSIA,
YOU DID NOT COLLUDE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> HE WENT ON TO SAY THAT IS
EVERY LIBERAL IN AMERICA.
THAT PART WAS FUNNY.
THAT MAY BE THE MOST TRUTHFUL
MOMENT OF THE WEEK.
THE PROBLEM IS WHEN POLITICS
BECOMES THE CENTER OF THESE
COMEDY SHOWS AND THE NARRATIVE
BEGINS TO FALL APART, THINGS
TURN NASTY.
VERY FAST.
>> OVER AT TRUMP TV, THEY WILL
AGREE THAT THIS WAS A TERRIBLE,
TERRIBLE THING AND THEY WANT
REVENGE.
IF YOU GOT RID OF ALL OF THE
CONSPIRACY THEORISTS,
PROPAGANDISTS, LIARS, FOX NEWS
WILL BE A BUNCH OF EMPTY
COUCHES.
>> WAIT A MINUTE.
THEY PROMOTED A STORY LINE THAT
FELL APART, BUT YOU ARE THE
LIAR, PROPAGANDISTS, AND
CONSPIRACY THEORIST?
I'M NOT FOLLOWING THIS AT ALL.
>> Laura: I LITERALLY HAVE
NEVER SEEN A SHOW BUT WAS HE A
BIG HIT ACROSS THE POND?
>> NO, HE'S A SOUTH AFRICAN.
>> Laura: THAT'S A BIG POND.
THAT'S HOW MUCH I DON'T KNOW
ABOUT HIM.
>> YOUR FOURTH STAGE OF GRIEF,
DEPRESSION, WAS ALL OVER FOR
STEPHEN COLBERT.
THE LAUGHS WERE FEW.
>> THIS WEEKEND WE RECEIVED SOME
TROUBLING NEWS.
OUR PRESIDENT IS NOT A RUSSIAN
ASSETS.
TRUMP IS NOT WORKING WITH THE
RUSSIANS.
WHAT THE HELL IS WRONG WITH HIM?
WHY DOES HE KEEP SAYING NICE
THINGS ABOUT VLADIMIR PUTIN?
>> Laura: IT DOESN'T WORK.
>> WHEN YOUR FIRST OBLIGATION IS
TO AN AGENDA AND NOT LAUGHS, IT
RUNS AGROUND FAST.
>> Laura: HE HASN'T BEEN FUNNY
SINCE HE WAS TRYING TO CHANNEL
O'REILLY.
>> HE WAS GREAT.
>> Laura: THAT GOT OLD.
THEY ARE ALWAYS LIVING
VICARIOUSLY.
>> PEOPLE WANT TO BUST A GUT.
THEY DON'T WANT HIM TO CUT
POLITICAL OPPONENTS.
HE REPORTED ON THE JUSSIE
SMOLLETT.
A CELEBRITY ESCAPING JUSTICE
BECAUSE HE IS A CELEBRITY.
HE'S NOT ALONE.
THERE'S A CULTURE OF CELEBRITY
INJUSTICE EMERGING.
VIDEO HIT SOCIAL MEDIA THIS WEEK
OF WRAPPER CARDI B TALKING ABOUT
HER PAST.
>> YEAH, YEAH, YEAH.
[BLEEP]
THAT'S WHAT I USED TO DO.
>> SHE IS SAYING SHE DRUGGED
PEOPLE AND ROBBED THEM.
SHE WOULD TAKE THEM TO HOTELS.
>> Laura: IMAGINE IF A WHITE
COUNTRY MUSIC STAR WENT ON
TELEVISION AND SAID THREE YEARS
AGO.
THAT WAS THREE YEARS AGO.
>> I WOULD DRUGGED THEM AND
ROBBED THEM.
THE AUTHORITIES WOULD BE BANGIN
BANGING.
ON THE CONCERT DOOR.
>> Laura: SHE'S A FASCINATING
FASCINATING --
>> SHE WAS SAYING THAT SHE WAS
JUST DOING WHAT SHE HAD TO DO TO
MAKE A LIVING.
>> Laura: THAT IS SORT OF THE
MAFIA.
THAT'S HOW THEY MAKE A LIVING.
>> DR. DRE THIS WEEK, HE BRAKED
ON INSTAGRAM THAT HIS DAUGHTER
GOT INTO USC WITH NO HELP FROM
HIM.
HE QUICKLY HAD TO PULL THAT
INSTRUMENT POSTING DOWN WHEN HE
WAS REMINDED THAT HE DONATED
$70 MILLION OF THE SCHOOL AND
THEY NAMED A BUILDING AFTER HIM
SEVERAL YEARS AGO.
THERE IS A DOUBLE STANDARD.
THEY JUST KEEP PLAYING IT.
>> Laura: YOU HAVE TO EXPLAIN
ONE THING.
I WAS CONFUSED BY THIS.
THIS VATICAN VIDEO EMERGED THAT
ENRAGED A LOT OF PEOPLE THIS
WEEK.
IT SHOWED POPE FRANCIS GRADING
PILGRIMS THAT WERE COMING TO
VISIT.
HE WITHHOLDS HIS RING.
THEY LIKE TO KISS THE RING.
IT'S KIND OF COOL.
WATCH.
>> HE NOT ONLY PULLS IT AWAY,
LAURA.
HE SWATS A FEW OF THESE POOR
PEOPLE.
I CALLED THE PAPAL PULLBACK.
ACCORDING TO THOSE CLOSE TO THE
POPE, HE'S UNCOMFORTABLE WITH
THE KISSING OF THE PAPAL RING.
THIS IS A MEDIEVAL HOLDOVER.
IT'S A WAY CATHOLICS OVER
CENTURIES HAVE SHOWN THEIR
RESPECT NOT FOR THE POPE BUT FOR
THE OFFICE.
IT'S THE OFFICE.
COULD YOU LET THEM KISS THE
RING.
WHY CAN'T THEY KISS THE RING IF
THEY WANT TO KISS THE RING?
>> AS DORA THE EXPLORER MIGHT
SAY, PAPA, STOPS WIPING.
THOUGH THE LAST TWO POPES DIDN'T
CARE FOR, THEY ALLOW PEOPLE TO
DO IT.
IT'S A SIGN OF GENEROSITY AND
RESPECT.
>> Laura: A FEW YEARS AGO.
>> HE INDULGED OTHERS.
HE DOES IT ALL THE TIME
ACTUALLY.
THERE ARE OTHER PEOPLE.
LOOK AT THIS PICTURE.
A GUY WHO WAS PERFORMING FOR
HIM, HE LOOKS VERY HAPPY TO HAVE
THEM KISS THE RING.
>> Laura: SEEMS DELIGHTED.
THAT'S A VERY COZY PHOTO.
>> TODAY THERE WAS A NUN IN THE
GENERAL AUDIENCE, SHE KISSED HIS
RING WITH NO PROBLEM AT ALL.
I THINK THERE IS AN ODD
DISCOMFORT HERE FOR SOME BUT HE
INDULGES A FEW OTHERS.
LAURA.
NOW IT'S YOUR MOMENT.
GO AHEAD.
SAY GOODBYE TO ME AND THE ONLY
WAY POSSIBLE --
>> Laura: GET OUT.
[LAUGHTER]
>> I WILL GIVE YOU THE
BENEDICTION ON THE WAY OUT.
>> Laura: I THINK IT'S FINE.
IF PEOPLE WANT TO KISS THE RING.
THE CHURCH HAS ENOUGH PROBLEMS.
LET THEM KISS THE RING.
IT'S VIRTUE SIGNALING.
LOOK AT ME.
IT'S NOT A CLERICAL --
ALL RIGHT.